what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
really really big news it is looking
like Harrison Ford is indeed joining the
MCU however not in the movie that we
thought he was going to be joining we
also have some more news about potential
Fantastic Four castings it's been a
little bit since we've heard about it in
fact we haven't really heard much about
the Fantastic forecasting after d23 some
insiders reported that Marvel Studios
was going to reveal the cast for The
Fantastic Four at d23 however of course
as we know that did not happen since
then we haven't really heard much but
today we have some new reports going
around about who could be cast as Sue
storm Reed Richards Johnny Storm and of
course Ben Grimm the thing and it looks
like as I talked about before last week
Marvel Studios could be making the Nova
project into a Disney plus special
special presentation if you caught my
video last week I talked about how
Marvel is going to be making some major
changes to the MCU how they are going to
start doing these specials more often
and it looks like they're doing this
with Nova turning it into a presentation
rather than a movie or a show we're
gonna go over each of these reports in
this video break down everything that
you need to know so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news so let's start with the Harrison
Ford casting for General Thunderbolt
Ross this rumor has been going around
for about a week and a half now and
originally it wasn't put out there as a
fact it was put out there more along the
lines of a statement that Harrison Ford
has met with Marvel Studios has talked
to them about the role however it was
not confirmed that he was indeed playing
Thunderbolt Russ however today that has
changed Jeff Snyder was the person who
originally reported on this but
yesterday on the hot mic podcast a
podcast that Jeff Snyder does with John
Roca Jeff Snyder came out and actually
said that this was confirmed he had
heard that it was confirmed Harrison
Ford is indeed playing Thunderbolt Ross
however he is not playing Thunderbolt
Ross in the Thunderbolts movie yet at
least but in fact the movie that he is
going to first appear in the MCU in is
Captain America 4 New World Order on the
podcast Jeff Snyder said that he asked
his Source if Harrison Ford had been
cast as Thunderbolt Ross in the
Thunderbolts film in which he said he
didn't get a confirmation but he goes on
to say that he figured perhaps he might
have asked the wrong question and it
appears that they might not have that
deal done yet for the Thunderbolts movie
however he says that he's heard that
they have closed a deal for a different
movie and that movie is Captain America
4. check out what he said right here
I hear
that Harrison Ford has in fact closed a
deal whoa to play General Thunderbolt
Ross and that the movie
is Captain America four wow
that's what I've heard wow I've heard
it's a done deal Harrison Ford
Thunderbolt Ross
Captain America four that's what I've
heard so there you have it Jeff Snyder
says that he's heard Harrison Ford is
joining the MCU he has been cast as
Thunderbolt Ross in Captain America 4.
and this actually makes sense because
Captain America knew World Order does
come before the Thunderbolts movie it
actually comes right before the
Thunderbolts movie so if they were going
to have Thunderbolt Ross appear in
Captain America 4 which based off of
everything we've heard multiple hulks
showing up the leader being the main
villain it does make sense for
Thunderbolt Ross to be in that film and
of course they would have to cast him
for that film first because it's before
the Thunderbolts so it looks like they
made that deal Harrison Ford is going to
be playing Thunderbolt Ross in the MCU
from now on because sadly William Hurt
the original actor who played him has
passed away he'll appear in Captain
America New World Order and then of
course I'm assuming he will show up in
the Thunderbolts as well I'm assuming
that deal is next to be made especially
considering that it's the very next
movie on The Phase 5 timeline so it
appears that we have our new Thunderbolt
Ross in the MCU and it is Harrison Ford
and he has a long history with Disney
specifically lucasfilm and Star Wars
which is owned by Disney now they are
also doing Indiana Jones as well so this
makes sense he's already a part of
Disney he just got done doing Indiana
Jones 5. he was already working very
close with them and now it looks like
he's going to continue to do so and I'm
excited I love Harrison Ford his
characters have been iconic and I think
he's going to bring a lot to the
character Thunderbolt Ross in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now moving on to the
new Fantastic Four casting rumors I
gotta say right off the bat I don't know
how I feel about this one so let me know
when you hear these what you think about
them in the comments down below this is
coming from the account demoy and if
you're not familiar with what demoy is
it's basically an account where people
can randomly submit things that they've
heard within the movie industry and some
other Industries as well so do not take
this as a confirmed thing not a
confirmed report just take it as a rumor
for now but this is what the message
says it says Fantastic Four News Maddie
Hassan and Tom Ellis are in the running
for the roles of Sue storm and Reed
Richards and they talk about Johnny and
the thing as well but let's first talk
about these two right here first off
Maddie Hassan admittedly I had never
heard of her before but after doing some
research and watching a few videos of
her I don't think that this would be a
bad choice I think she definitely has a
look to play Sue storm and she had some
real talent and great acting
capabilities in some of the clips that I
saw of her so I don't doubt that she
would do a good job and then there's
also Tom Ellis who most people know from
the series Lucifer now Tom Ellis is a
great actor I have nothing against him
however out of all of the people that
we've heard to play Reed Richards and
Sue storm I still think I'm leaning more
towards pin Badgley well of course I'm
leaning towards John Krasinski and his
wife Emily Blunt but if it's not going
to be the two of them I'm leaning more
towards pin Badgley and Jody Comer but
that is just a personal preference of
mine like I said Maddie Hassan and Tom
Ellis are great actors and I believe
they would do a great job playing Reed
and Sue however I just kind of see it
more with Penn Badgley and Jody Comer
but let me know what you think down
below now this rumor is not over it
continues to say Davey Diggs has also
auditioned Michael Provost is the
favorite for Johnny Storm Jason Biggs
has auditioned for the thing now this is
very interesting it doesn't say who
David Diggs has auditioned for it just
says he auditioned so this could be for
Reed Richards it could be for Johnny
Storm or it could be the thing however I
kind of don't hope he plays the thing I
think he's got a lot of talent I'd
really like to see his natural face on
screen and not covered up with rock
however he'd still probably do a pretty
good job now Jason Biggs is kind of
weird not gonna lie most people know
Jason Biggs from the American Pie
franchise of course he's been in a lot
of other movies since then and no doubt
that he is a talented actor and keep in
mind it's not going to be his actual
body playing the thing of course it's
going to be probably mocap remember Mark
Ruffalo isn't actually the size of the
Hulk and if they are going to go down
sort of the comedy route Jason Biggs
might do really well in this role
however I'm still kind of leaning
towards the Seth Rogen casting if I had
to choose if they truly are going down
that comedic route but like I said this
is not confirmed this is just a casting
rumor take it with a grain of salt and
of course if I hear anything else I'll
be sure to do an updated video but let
me know what you think about this rumor
for these actors to play The Fantastic
Four in the comments down below and now
finally moving on to Nova in a recent
report yesterday from
thecosmiccircus.com they have said that
they heard Marvel Studios is making
Nova's introduction to the MCU a Disney
plus special presentation now the last
time I was talking about this people had
not seen werewolf by night yet however
it has come out now and a lot of people
have said that they really really
enjoyed it I'm one of these people and I
actually do think think that these
specials are kind of cool and they could
be a really interesting way to introduce
new characters to the MCU of course I
gotta say that I would prefer Nova to
have his own movie however a short
little one hour special to introduce him
then him maybe appear in the Guardians
of the Galaxy or another Cosmic film in
the MCU and then go on to get his own
true film in the MCU might not be that
bad and if it means that we get Nova in
the MCU sooner rather than later because
of the special I'm here for it I'd
rather get him in the MCU in a special
in a year rather than waiting two to
three years for him to appear in the MCU
in his own movie or Disney Plus show
because like I said a Disney plus
special presentation gets him in the MCU
and then he can appear in other films if
quickly introducing Nova into the MCU
during a special presentation gets him
in Avengers Secret Wars do it I'd rather
that happen than to not see him in
secret Wars at all but hey let me know
your thoughts about all of these reports
in the comments down below let me know
what you think don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to the channel so
you can stay up to date on all the
recent MCU news of course you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter for live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof